Welcome, students,
to the second part of
our pharmacology of
antibiotics, the beta
-lactams, other cell wall
inhibitors, and we'll
talk about one-cell
membrane inhibitor.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
The drugs we'll
talk about are
the cephalosporins,
carbapenems,
there is one monobactam,
vancomycin,
and daptomycin.
Please contact me
if you or your study
group would like
to sit with me and
have a pharmacology
chat. Of course,
we can do this in
person or by Zoom.
The learning
objectives are
the same as for
part one because
this really is
one lecture.
Learning objectives
are not meant to
be taken as discrete
learning issues.
Everything is
interrelated.
You need to be able to
look at the learning
objectives and think
about them as a whole.
Mechanisms, mechanisms,
mechanisms, and
patient safety.
Preparation materials
are as for part one
and I put lots of
information in part
one, the key points
that you need to know.
So let's start talking
about the cephalosporins.
The figure here
on the left hand
upper side shows our
beta-lactam ring that
you're all familiar
with now and this
ring is a little different
than the penicillin
so it gives them
different activities
the cephalosporins
have been developed
over decades the
drug that was first
was was became first
generation as drugs
developed later and
later and later and later
became second generation,
third generation,
fourth generation,
and the most recently
developed ones don't
really fit very well
into the previous
categories, so they've
been called by various
names. I'll just call
them advanced generation
cephalosporins.
This is the largest
group of beta-lactam
antibiotics. I have
selected some from
one or some from
each category. This
is certainly not all
of the cephalosporins
that have been
developed, but they're
the ones that are
most used and they
have important
pharmacologic features.
I will also be
showing you spectrums
of activity, the
same way I did before
with the penicillins
group, where we
have the list and we
block out features
where the drugs
are not effective.
So first generation,
cefazolin.
This is parenterol.
This is all later.
You don't have to
write this down.
And cefalexin, which
is oral. So
basically, we have our
choice of injection
or oral therapy.
Second generation,
and second
generation has
a subgroup. I'll
get into this
in more detail.
Third generation,
very important, very,
very important
group, widely used.
and that there's
one subgroup in this
category fourth generation
there's only one
drug in the category
this is a quite a broad
-spectrum drug and
then our advanced
generation I'll get into
that more later when
I when you see a
star on a drug. That
means that, of course,
as with all pharmacology
lectures, you need
to know the main
concepts, the class
effects, and then I will
give you certain
drugs to know by name.
Make them your friends.
When you are in
your clinical
rotations you'll
need to be able
to call drugs
by their names.
Now it's a little
difficult here because
cephalosporins all
start with Ceph. Well
the good thing is
you know it's a
cephalosporin. The bad
thing is it's kind of
hard to keep these
drug names straight.
Some students have
told me they make
mnemonics out of the
last part of the drug,
the part after Ceph,
and that helps them
to remember the drugs.
I don't have a good
mnemonic for you.
I suggest maybe AI
can help you with that
and many of you are
very clever with it
and can come up with
your own mnemonics
which I strongly
encourage you to share
with your classmates.
Class pharmacokinetic
properties and nearly
all All of these
drugs fall into this
general category, either
IM or IV, and oral.
They distribute to
most body fluids and
tissues, so widely
distributed, to
the bile and gallbladder,
the liver and
kidneys, the bone
and synovial fluid.
They cross the placenta,
they enter breast milk.
These are eight
different locations,
but they have been
chunked together.
just sort of
imagine a body and
think about where
the drugs are going.
CSF *********** is
poor we saw that
with the penicillins
group as well.
Now here are the
exceptions and all
of these drugs
have stars on them.
Cefuroxine is
second generation.
These three are third gen
and this is
the fourth gen.
These are all
somewhat structurally
related and they
all have better CSF
*********** than we
saw with the earlier
penicillins group.
Of course, when the
meninges are inflamed,
higher concentrations
are achieved
in the cerebral
spinal fluid.
All right, so what are
we talking about here?
If we have better
CSF ***********,
Assuming effectiveness,
think meningitis
treatment.
Try and put these
concepts together.
We eliminated
glomerular filtration
and secretion of
unchanged drug,
just like the
beta-lactam's
general pharmacokinetic
properties.
There is an exception.
This is ceftriaxone,
super important drug.
Triaxone, triaxone,
triaxone, ceftriaxone,
oop, excuse me, I
pushed the wrong button.
Biliary excretion,
therefore the
adjustment for
renal impairment,
dose adjustment,
is not required.
and then the advanced
generations are also
excreted in the urine
as active drug now
half-life short we
thought we talked about
that with the penicillins
another exception
ceftriaxone once
a day except for
meningitis in which
we need higher
concentrations of
drug to get into and
kill that organism,
it's twice a day.
Please know these
terms, these features.
This is just a scheme.
The spectrums of
action generally
increase through
the generations.
This makes sense because
the first generation,
cephalosporins of
which cefazolin is
the prototype have
gram positive gram
positive and very
little gram negative so
streptococci methicillin
sensitive staph
aureus so it's an
alternative to the penicillin
penicillinase resistant
group although
the penicillinase
resistant group are
generally preferred
because they're more
active, they act
more quickly than the
cephalosporins, but
these are a good option.
And the gram negative,
P-E-K,
well C-K,
proteus, E. coli,
and Klebsiella,
makes it easy
to remember.
So first generation
spectrum of action,
aerobic gram-positive,
including MSSA,
and the gram-negatives,
enterobacteriales,
or Proteus, E. coli,
Klebsiella, PEC.
Second generation,
okay.
Well, we didn't get
much gram-negative
out of it, so they
were developed
to increase gram
-negative activity.
And we pick up a few
respiratory
organisms here.
Moricella and
Haemophilus.
Okay, now there's
another group
in here, a subgroup.
These are called
cefamycins
because they come
from a different
microbial source.
These are effective
against Bacteroides
fragilis, that obligate
anaerobe that's
difficult to treat. Of
course, resistance is
rising. We need to
always remember that.
But susceptible
Bacteroides
fragilis will respond
to cefamycins.
They also have
this activity.
Third generation, as I
said, super
important group.
They have good
activity against the
gram positives,
including pneumococci.
except septazidine
oh there's
always got to be
an exception right
septazidine is good
against pseudomonas the
others the others that
we saw above are not
fourth generation
this is a broad
spectrum well
extended spectrum
but much broader
than above
enteric non-enteric
gram-negative bacteria
and pseudomonas
you see how it's
increasing as we go
down cefepime is more
stable against certain
chromosomal beta
-lactamases of the gram
-negative That said,
there are many organisms
that produce beta
-lactamases that none
of the cephalosporins,
or beta-lactams actually,
will respond to.
Advanced generation.
I'll get to
that in a couple
of slides. Okay,
so our first generation,
narrow spectrum,
we see this and
this. That's it.
Easy to remember.
our second generation
oops let's go back
just watch this don't
write first generation
second generation
we pick up a few more
plus the cefamycins
here third generation
you see it's
expanding the
enterobacteriales, this is
the gut bugs,
facultative anaerobic gut
bugs, we call them
gram-negative aerobes,
aerobic bacilli,
quite a few.
This remains the
same, this
doesn't change,
so try and group
this and develop
patterns. Oh,
look at this,
gonorrhea,
ceftriaxone.
Please remember
ceftriaxone and gonorrhea.
And spirochetes.
Ceftriaxone is good for a
lot of different
infections.
Now the fourth
generation. This
is the difference
here from the third
generation. Stable to
many beta-lactamases, but
not stable to also
many beta-lactamases.
now our advanced
generation there
are different
authors put different
drugs in this group
i'm just putting
these two in here
this is how i see
it so ceftaroline
and cefiterolol
The big claim to fame
for cefteraline is MRSA.
This is the only beta
-lactam available in
the United States that
has activity against
methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus
aureus. It also has
activity against penicillin
-resistant streptococcus
pneumoniae.
Cephidrocol is an
interesting drug.
This is the one
that's very recently
been developed
compared to the
others. It chelates
free iron, ferric
ions, in the
extracellular spaces.
This complexing together
with the iron allows
sephitricol to pass
into gram-negative
aerobic bacteria by
their iron transport
systems. So it gets
through that outer membrane
reaches the PBP target
and is therefore
effective against
these aerobic gram
-negative organisms. So
I've made a chart here,
ceftarolene here,
cefiterolol here.
Cefiterolol is just
these gram-negative
aerobic enteric, but
that's a big just.
It is effective
against multidrug
-resistant gram-negative
bacteria, ESBL and
AMPC-producing,
multidrug-resistant
GNBs, and pseudomonas,
an important drug.
Of course, I believe
we'll be seeing
resistance in
the future. There
are already signs
of it, and it
hasn't been around
all that long.
Cepterolene, we see
our grand positives,
and we have some
grand negative aerobic
enteric bugs and
non-enteric bugs.
What are we using
these two drugs for?
let's look at
the federal call
first hospital
acquired and
ventilator
associated pneumonia
complicated urinary
tract infections multi
-drug resistant
pseudomonas infections
easy to remember
complicated drugs that
have bugs that have
multi-drug resistance
ceftarolene well
streptococcus pneumoniae
causes pneumonia so
community acquired
pneumonia hospital
acquired pneumonia so
bugs that have been
acquired in the hospital
and ventilator
associated pneumonia
bacteremia and skin and
soft tissue infection
so if you can sort
of chunk these ideas,
see the patterns,
make your own tables.
This
apparently really dense
material, antibiotic
therapies, will
start to come clear
for you and you'll start
to see the patterns,
you'll start to
chunk ideas together.
And if you can do
that now you'll be
reminded of these as
we go along and you'll
see them in clinical
in your clinical
rotations you'll appreciate
it in the future.
Acquired resistance
naturally beta
-lactamase production
and altered PBPs,
ESBLs, extended spectrum
beta-lactamases,
is resistance to
all penicillins
and cephalosporins,
multidrug
resistance, bacteroides,
it's intrinsically
resistant to
many antibiotics,
cefamycins,
these, I only have one
that's starred,
cefoxitin,
foxy cefoxitin
is good against
this tough
bacteroides fragilis.
Amp-C beta-lactamases.
So the early beta
-lactamase inhibitors
are not effective
against the Amp-C, but
the later beta-lactamase
inhibitors are.
Amp-C are chromosomally
encoded and inducible.
They also can pass
through peloporins.
I have not starred
these organisms. You do
not need to memorize
them, but I have seen
them appear on board
practice questions.
Altered target penicillin
binding proteins.
These organisms that
have these altered PVPs
are resistant to all
cephalosporins except
for this one which is
ceftaroline but all
the rest are susceptible
anterococcus listeria
and of course the
atypical respiratory
pathogens all the beta
-lactamins are unable to
eradicate them either
because like mycoplasma,
it doesn't have a
peptidoglycancel wall,
or legionella and
chlamytophila,
which are obligate
intracellular.
They're all not
active against C.
difficile, so we
can get C. difficile
infections with the
use of the antibiotics.
And Campylobacter
jejuni, I did not put,
I did not emphasized
to you. It is a really
an important cause
of acute diarrhea,
especially in
kids, and the
cephalosporins
are ineffective.
Resistence.
Gram positive,
the MDR, Streptococcus
pneumoniae, except
ceftaroline,
MRSA, except ceftaroline,
Enterococcus,
Listeria, C. difficile.
Of the gram
-negatives, the KPC
-producing
enterobacteriales,
campylobacter,
stenotrophomonas,
which I did not put
a star on, but it's
multidrug-resistant
intrinsically.
Acinetobacter,
the same thing.
Atypicals I just
talked about.
this is the generations
all put on one
table for their
therapeutic use we remember
the first generation
or gram positive
impact so what do
we think about with
gram positive think
about skin flora
gram positive skin
flora skin infections
gram positive can also
cause uncomplicated
urinary tract
infections certain ones
that i didn't
emphasize that you know
and proteus e coli
and klebsiella
so we use the fazolin for
surgical prophylaxis
it's given
within an hour
of surgery to
prevent the infection
by skin flora
cephalexin is oral
can be used for
uncomplicated infections
second generation is not
used for much to tell
you the truth the
second generation are
not as good not as
active against gram
positive as the first
generation and they're
not as active as the
third generation
against gram negatives
and I haven't put on
here the oral third
-generation agents,
except for Seftonair.
Seftonair is
widely, widely used.
You're going to
see that in your
clinical rotations.
Others also.
But the oral agents
are better than the
oral agents of the
second generation for
treating upper
respiratory, lower
respiratory tract
infections UTIs otitis media
that sort of thing
fourth generation
severe infections it's
broad spectrum and
that's what we
usually reserve it for
advanced generation
well MRSA think
skin flora so skin
skin structure
infections community
acquired pneumonia
these are the main
therapeutic uses
of cefiterolene,
cefiterocol, all those
things that I went
through before.
Now, all of the
parenteral cephalosporins
can cause
thrombophobitis when
given intravenously,
and the intramuscular
injection is
kind of painful.
Third generation
cephalosporins are most
commonly prescribed.
So why is this?
Well, they're effective
against a number
of common infections.
They have this
extended spectrum of
activity, it's called.
They get those GNBs.
Stable against
the common beta
-lactamases of the
gram-negative bacilli.
Common.
The gram-positive bacteria,
they have activity
against penicillin
non-susceptible strep
pneumoniae. It's
called non-susceptible.
and other gram
-positive species.
It's less potent activity
against methicillin
-sensitive staph
aureus. Remember, the
nafcillin group of
the penicillins, these
are the most active,
they work quickly.
And the first generation,
cefazolin, and its oral
counterpart, are
preferred for MSSA.
The third
-generation cefts are
highly active
against the gut bugs.
Neisseria meningitidis,
so meningitis
caused by Neisseria
meningitis,
and meningitis caused
by other organisms,
such as Streptococcus
pneumoniae,
such as Haemophilus
influenzae.
But ceftazidime and
a newer one now,
ceftolazine, which is
hooked up with tazobactam,
are the only ones
in this group that
have Pseudomonas
aeruginosa activity.
Important to remember.
cefotaxime and ceftriaxone
we think of together
and i'll go into that
in more detail on
the next slide they are
agents of choice for
the treatment of
meningitis how important is
it well meningitis is
deadly and we need to
know the drugs that
are effective and safe
ceftriaxone a single
IM injection is the
only CDC recommended
treatment of uncomplicated
gonorrhea. How
important is it to know
this? It's the only
drug that's really,
really effective at
this point. Many drugs
have been effective
in the past. However,
Neisseria gonorrhea
has developed
considerable multi
-drug resistance.
Ceftriaxone and
cefotaxime, first of
all, they have the same
spectrum of activity,
both administered
parenterally,
they're widely
distributed in body fluids
and tissues, including
the cerebral spinal
fluid, especially
in patients with
meningitis. So what
differentiates them?
You need to know this.
Ceftriaxone is
on this side,
cefotaxime is
on this side.
Ceftriaxone is eliminated
via the biliary system.
So it goes out through
the liver into the gut.
It's not metabolized,
but it goes out that way.
So high concentrations
are going to be
in the gallbladder,
which makes it really
useful for acute
cholecystitis but
it can also cause
biliary sludging and
gallstone formation.
This is not something
that's going to
happen with one dose
or a few doses.
It's more long term.
Cephotaxine goes
out unchanged in the
urine just like
the general class
effects of the beta
lactams actually.
Ceftriaxone does not
need dose adjustment
in patients with
renal impairment.
Cefotaxime, look it
up in the literature
and see what the
dosing recommendations
are for patients with
renal impairment.
Ceftriaxone has that
longer half-life.
Cefotaxime is short,
requires every
six to eight hours
dosing compared
to ceftriaxone's
one-time daily.
Uh-oh, let's talk
about babies.
Brand new
babies, neonates.
Cephotaxime is
preferred in neonates.
Well, why in the
world is that?
Let's see the difference.
Ceftriaxone is highly
bound to plasma
proteins, so
it's quite potent
on those plasma
proteins, and it can
displace unconjugated
bilirubin.
Neonates have
immature metabolic
systems and renal
systems because
they're brand
new. Their systems
are going to
continue to mature.
As a result,
this unconjugated
bilirubin floats around
as free bilirubin
in the bloodstream.
Well, neonates also
have a leaky blood
-brain barrier because
it's not fully
mature, especially
********* neonates.
The unconjugated bilirubin
can move into the
CNS tissues, and that
can cause encephalopathy
in the newborn. And
that encephalopathy
is called kernicterus.
It will be worth
your time to learn
this word, kernicterus,
and what it is. I
suggest you might want to
look it up. It will
only take you a few
minutes, but it will
help you understand how
serious kernicterus
can be, encephalopathy.
Now that's one, the
hyperbilirubinemia. Two,
ceftriaxone can cause
precipitation of
calcium in calcium
-containing solutions.
It forms a complex
with calcium, and
it precipitates.
And this precipitant
can deposit in lung
and kidney tissues
and damage those
tissues in the neonate.
Cephaltaxime
doesn't do any of
these things. That's
why cephalotaxime
is preferred in neonates.
Adverse effects?
Well, painful IM
injection, thrombophlebitis
from the IV,
renal tubular
necrosis, and
interstitial nephritis
are reported.
They're fortunately
rare, but
they can have
serious consequences,
so we just
monitor for them.
Ceftriaxone,
biliary stasis,
cholestatic hepatitis
makes sense because
it goes out
through the biliary
system. Neonates
I talked about.
Cephotetin does not
have a star. I have
seen this in the board
review questions.
Cephotetin can cause
hypoprothrombinemia
and And it can cause
this disulfiram type of
reaction, which
simply means flushing,
nausea, vomiting, when
the drug is given to a
patient who has alcohol
in the bloodstream.
That's it.
I'm not going to go
over these check your
knowledge questions
because I don't want
to extend the time
of this lecture
unduly, but they're here
for you. I recommend
that you pause the
video and while
it's still fresh in your
mind, try and answer
these questions
without looking at the
answers. The answers
are listed in the
end of this video
and also we just saw
everything coming up
to these questions.
So the carbapenems
now. I put
stars really
on two of them,
but two of them
are combined with
a beta-lactamase
inhibitor. So So
remember two and
remember them
with the beta
-lactamase inhibitor.
So let's talk first
about psilastatin.
Imapenem was the first
of the carbapenems
to be developed,
and it needed to
be combined with
psilastatin. So is
psilastatin a beta
-lactamase inhibitor?
No. So, psilostatin
inhibits an enzyme
in the kidneys called
dehydropeptidase
1. It's located
in the proximal
renal tubule, and
there's a brushboard
in there, so
that's where it is.
Dehydropeptidase 1
inactivates imipenem. So,
by putting the
psilostatin in there, that
blocks this drug, the
actions of the drug
to inactivate
imipenem. So, imipenem,
psilostatin levels are
high in the urine, which
makes it useful for
infections in the urinary
tract, including
complicated infections.
Meropenem came along
second, and there
are very little
difference between these
in terms of the
spectrum of action.
Of course, as
we've talked about,
multi-drug resistant
organisms, carbapenemase
producing enhancing
gram-negative
bacteria that are resistant
to all beta-lactams,
including the
carbapenems. Carbapenems
were developed specifically
for the purpose
of being stable in
the presence of beta
-lactamases. But of
course the organisms,
because of
selection pressure,
because of their
random mutations
that bacteria make
developed resistance
to the carbapenems
as well.
So you may recall that
relibactam, babrobactam
are effective against
those KPC producing
and AMPC producing
bacteria. So that's why
they've been combined
here. So, I'm not
asking you to remember
ertapenem or dorapenem.
You may be expected
to know that
at some future
point, but you
don't need to
know it for now.
Spectrum of
action. Look at
how broad spectrum
these are.
Stable to many beta
-lactamases, as I said.
So the enterobacteriales,
they are able,
especially with their
beta-lactamase inhibitor,
able to treat
infections, serious
infections caused
by these organisms.
Again, enterococcus
faecium
is not susceptible to it.
clostridium clostridioides
difficile is
not susceptible we
see that we think
overgrowth think secondary
infection otherwise
pretty broad
spectrum think about
the pattern chunk
things together it's
easier than memorizing
each and every bug
broad spectrum
some resistance
as i mentioned
gram positive
gram negative
aerobic anaerobic
Penicillin-resistant
streptococcus
pneumoniae. While
there are other
drugs, there are
not quite as broad
spectrum that
might be preferred.
Penicillin-sensitive
enterococcus
fecalis, not Fesium.
Stable to most beta
-lactamases, but not the
carbapenemases or
metallobeta-lactamases.
Treatment of choice
for ESBL-expressing
enterobacteriales,
anaerobes including
B fragilis,
pseudomonas aeruginosa.
Pseudomonas is known for
developing resistance
during therapy
so very often if
pseudomonas is identified
or suspected two anti
-pseudomonas drugs
will be put together.
Now pseudomonas this
is the exception
Erdapenem.
As I said, I'm not
asking you to remember
Erdapenem. It's the
sort of thing that
could appear on a board
exam and certainly
you need to know it
if you're going to
be taking an infectious
disease rotation.
KPCs, metallobetalactamases
resistance.
Intrinsic resistance.
When you have a broad
-spectrum drug in
front of you, it's
just so much easier
to remember what's
resistant to it,
intrinsically resistant,
than trying to
enumerate everything
that it's effective
against that's susceptible
to it. So MRSA,
Enderococcus faecium,
C. difficile,
and this crazy MDR bug,
Stenotrophomonas
multifilla.
That's something you will
like to know
about later on.
Treatment with
carbapenos.
Basically, serious
infections. infections,
lower respiratory,
intra-abdominal,
pelvic, skin, soft
tissue, bone joint. So
serious infections
in many locations
caused by especially
gram-negative organisms,
but possibly by
gram-positive
bacteria. But we have
other drugs really that
are not as huge
spectrum that are also
effective against
the gram positive.
Adverse effects,
seizures,
especially imipenem,
especially people
with renal
insufficiency. Why renal
insufficiency? Because
they're not clearing the
drug as efficiently
as a healthy kidney,
and the blood levels
can accumulate,
the drug can get into
the CNS, and high
concentration is enough
to cause seizures.
Bleeding,
agranulocytosis.
These are seen.
They don't happen.
They're fairly
rare, not completely
rare. So what do we
do? we watch for it.
GI nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
pretty common. When
I say diarrhea,
unless I say C.
difficile associated
diarrhea, I'm
just talking about
non-secondary
infection diarrhea
and C. difficile
super infection.
So let's talk about
now what happens
when we add the beta
-lactamase inhibitor.
Inhibit Ambler class
A beta-lactamases,
including KPCs,
and also the class
C, AMP-C beta
-lactamases, but not the
metallobeta-lactamases.
None of the drugs
is effective against
organisms that
produce those
metallobeta-lactamases.
Relobactam improves
imipenem activity
against most
enterobacteriallies
and non-susceptible
pseudomonas.
Vabrobactam improves
meropenem activity
against most of the
enterobacteriallies.
Relobactam does not
improve imipenem
activity against
these two multi
-drug resistant
organisms that I have
not asked you to
memorize by name.
But I must mention these
things for context.
Vabrobactam has not
shown to improve
meropenem
activity against
Pseudomonas or these
other two bad bugs.
Finally,
the monobactam astreanam.
Finally, in terms
of beta-lactams,
You may notice
the structure
looks quite different.
This ring here
is not attached
to the beta-lactam ring.
So that's why
it's called a
monobactam. The beta
-lactam ring is kind
of hanging out
here by itself.
IV, IM, widely
distributed, renal
excretion. Here's the
big takeaway with S
-trianam. Only gram
-negative aerobic
cocci and bacilli,
including Pseudomonas
aeruginosa. You see
the pattern here?
Chunk it all together.
Gram-negative
aerobic organisms,
including Pseudomonas.
So resistance,
gram-positives, and some
of the enterobacteriales.
Sorry, I keep pushing
that wrong. button.
ESBLs, KPC, AMPC beta
-lactamases, and of
course the metallo
-beta-lactamases will,
organisms producing
these will
be resistant to
the Aztreonam.
What do we use it
for? Well, it's going
to be renally
excreted, producing
high concentrations
of active drug in
the urine, so urinary
tract infections.
Also,
gram-negative lower
respiratory
tract infections.
Bacteremia, skin
and skin structure,
intra-abdominal
pelvic infections.
So it's got a lot
of uses as long
as it's gram
-negative infections.
Interestingly,
cystic fibrosis
patients, which have
just gunk in
their lungs, tend
to get pseudomonas
lung infections.
So astreanam has
been developed into
an inhalation
product so that the
patient can just
breathe in the
astreanam, which
will go in high
concentrations right
into the lung tissue.
So thinking about
empiric therapy.
Remember empiric
therapy? That's when we
don't know what the
organism is. the patient
is presenting with
signs and symptoms
of infection. We
can't wait to treat
it, so we have to
use a broad-spectrum
organisms that's
going to hit the gram
-positive and gram
-negative potential
pathogens that it's
causing the infection.
So we cannot use
STRIANAM. It's got a
narrow spectrum,
gram-negative only.
Aerobes.
It has a low immunogenic
potential. We've
been talking about
cross-reactivity.
Anybody who has a
penicillin allergy with
anaphylaxis, what is
the likelihood that
the patient will have
an allergic reaction
to other beta-lactams?
Well, Astrianam
has a very low
immunogenic potential. You
may recall the
structure is completely
different than the
others. There is one
exception and that is
ceftazidine. If a person
has had an anaphylactic
response to
ceftazidine they really
should not get estrianab
because it has a
similar side chain.
Usual common adverse
effects of antibiotics,
IV, thrombophlebitis,
yes C.
difficile super
infection is a potential.
So there are many
similarities of
Astrianam with
the class effects.
this is different
and this is different
so moving now away
from our beta-lactams
to vancomycin which
is the only cell
wall inhibitor I have
put a I should say
non-beta-lactam cell
wall inhibitor that
I've put a star
on vancomycin is a
glycopeptide we see
the sugar residues here
and here is this big
ol looking protein.
It's a peptide.
Vancomycin is not
absorbed from the gut so
we can't give it ******.
It's administered
only IV for systemic
infections by slow infusion
in a dilute solution
because of a particular
adverse effect called
Redman syndrome,
which causes erythema,
flushing, and it's not
immune-related. It's
related directly to the
vancomycin, causing
the systemine release.
Widely distributed in
tissues and fluids.
It stays in the tissues
and fluids. It's not
going to cross into
intracellular spaces.
like the beta-lactams
low ***********
of the csf unless
the meninges are
inflamed like
the beta-lactams
glomerular filtration
of unchanged drug
half-life well this
is really going to
depend on renal
function vancomycin can
cause nephrotoxicity
and nephrotoxicity
during therapy can
reduce renal function.
So in a patient who
has excellent renal
function, the half-life
is about six hours.
But as that renal
function decreases,
the frequency
and dose of the
vancomycin need
to be reduced.
extending the
dosing interval and
lowering the dose
and or depending
on what the
renal function is
t greater than mic pkpd
profile and a short
antibiotic effect
And clinical efficacy
correlates with 24
-hour AUC to MIC ratio.
So the AUC to MIC
ratio is dependent. The
dose based on AUC to
MIC ratio is dependent
on the organism being
treated. So I've given
you an example here.
You don't need to
memorize these numbers,
but I think it will
help you to conceptualize
what we're talking
about with this PKPD
24-hour AUC to MIC
ratio concept of dosing
to maximize efficacy.
And in the case
of vancomycin, it
actually minimizes
nephrotoxicity. So,
for MRSA, which
is a major use of
vancomycin, if the 24
-hour AUC to MIC ratio
falls between 400
and 600, the clinical
correlation with
success of therapy
for MRSA is demonstrated
by this number.
Bactericidal,
most of the time.
Mechanism of action.
This is that big
vancomycin chemical again.
It has affinity for
the D-alladiala on the
pentapeptide chain.
So this is right
here. and by hooking
up with that part of
the pentapeptide it
prevents the building
blocks to come together
so that's called
transglycosylation
it prevents the
transglycosylation step
which is why they have
vancomycin right
here it doesn't block
transglycosylase it
just prevents the step
because it's created
this big bulky thing.
And that's really
basically it.
Now let's talk
resistance.
Changing of the
site of action.
Some of these
organisms, Enterococci,
it's effective against
Enterococci, and
staphylococcus aureus.
So enterococci can
change the site here
from d-alladiala to
d-alladilactate. So d
-alladilactate. And
that's going to reduce
the affinity for
vancomycin such that
vancomycin becomes
completely ineffective.
Some more
information here.
Spectrum of action.
So important. Gram
-positive only. How easy
is that to remember?
Gram-positive only.
Particularly MRSA.
MRSA, MRSA, MRSA.
So vancomycin
has been for many
decades the go-to
drug for the
treatment of MRSA.
Of course, it'll be
effective against
MSSA and MSSE, but
the penicillinase
-resistant penicillins,
the napcillin group,
have better activity than
vancomycin, and
they're preferred.
Vanco is also useful
against penicillin-
resistant streptococcus
pneumoniae,
enterococcus fecalis,
and enterococcus faecium.
That's the first
time we've seen that,
that anterococcus
faecium is susceptible.
Intrinsic
resistance. Well,
all gram negatives.
That's it.
That big bulky
molecule just
can't get through
the porins.
And mycobacteria,
the drug doesn't
get through the
cell wall of the
mycobacteria.
Mycobacteria, for example,
cause tuberculosis.
Now, I mentioned
the DL-D-lactate
preventing
vancomycin binding,
so that's high
-level resistance.
Staph aureus,
well plasmids can, I
mean the Van A gene
cluster can be passed
on through plasmids
to staph aureus
and now that's high
level resistance for
staph aureus too.
and also Staph aureus
there's an this is
intermediate resistance
it seems that
the organism can
develop this thick cell
wall because it's
got a lots of DL more
than usual and that'll
trap the vancomycin
within the cell
cell wall And as a
result, the drug is
just not going to be as
available to reduce
the MRSA infection.
So MRSA,
you name it, anywhere the
drug can get to, MRSA.
Bacteremia,
pneumonia, empyema,
that's a ***** infection.
endocarditis,
osteomyelitis, skin
soft tissue
abscess, and more.
Penicillin-resistant
enterococcus
endocarditis.
And if the organism
is not known,
if it's suspected
to be resistant,
then vancomycin will just
be used as
empiric therapy.
Meningitis due to
penicillinase-resistant
streptococcus
pneumoniae. gram-positive
infections in penicillin
-allergic patients.
So here is an
option for people
who have a
penicillin allergy
and a gram
-positive injection.
Now, C. difficile.
Every single drug
up till now has
been a potential
cause of C. Well,
oral vancomycin,
which of course is not
absorbed from the
GI tract, will move
through the intestine
to the gut, to the
lower small intestine
and large intestine,
and it is used to
treat C. difficile.
Oral vancomycin to treat
C. difficile infection.
C. difficile, remember,
is a gram positive
anaerobic rod and
vancomycin is effective.
Cautions, well,
nephrotoxicity.
Acute kidney injury
can occur and this is
usually in patients who
already have multiple
risk factors for
acute kidney injury.
Still we watch that
kidney function closely.
Non-immune
anaphylactoid infusion
related reaction.
This is the
red so-called
red man syndrome,
but patients
can have a true
hypersensitivity
reaction.
Phlebitis at the
injection site.
Some patients really
do need to get
long-term therapy
such as endocarditis
and we need to be
looking at white blood
cell count.
Neutropenia can occur.
Ototoxicity it's
much more rare
than it used to be
in the beginning
because vancomycin
which is a
natural substance
it comes from
a natural product
is much purer
now than it was
in the beginning.
Drug interactions.
Well, drugs with
the same toxicities,
especially
nephrotoxicity.
Ototoxicity, while rare,
becomes more likely
with other drugs that
cause ototoxicity.
So, nephrotoxicity, what
are we thinking about?
Aminoglycosides,
because we are going
to talk about this
group of drugs.
Diuretics,
loop diuretics.
Amphotericin B and
NSAIDs. Now I know for
you right now this
is just kind of
memorization but I would
like you to remember
all of these. They
are so so important.
So what do we do?
Well if a drug causes
adverse effects, does
it mean we can't use
it? Well, sometimes
it's contraindicated,
but most of the time
we remain vigilant.
So how do we do that?
We monitor. So in terms
of vancomycin, we
monitor the serum
levels. We want to keep
the vancomycin in that
range. So for example
MRSA we want to
keep it in this 400 to
600 AUC to MIC ratio
and we do that by
taking serum levels over
time and figuring out
the AUC we already
know the MIC from the
microbiology lab and
of course we monitor
signs and symptoms
always always monitor
for the signs and
symptoms of adverse
effects and we have to
let especially with
oral therapy when the
patient's going home
you have to let them
know what to expect
but we should do that
in the hospital too
so our non-immune
anaphylactoid meaning it
looks like anaphylaxis,
but it isn't. It's
like anaphylaxis. So
anaphylactoid infusion
-related reaction.
We see on the
left this very
light-skinned
individual, so it's
easy to make out
the flushing.
Here on the trunk,
and on the neck, and
face, and see how
flushed it is. And on the
right hand side, we
have a darker skinned
individual, and it's
not as easy to identify.
However, if the
patient is complaining
about this hot feeling,
hot kind of itchy
feeling on their
chest, neck, and face,
then you know the
infusion is going in
too fast and or is
not dilute enough.
So this is not a
reason to withdraw the
therapy. It just
has to be adjusted.
And our last
drug that we'll
talk about is daptomycin.
It is a cyclic
lipopeptide. So
here's the lipid
component and here
is the circular
peptide component.
This part you may
need to know for the
boards. You don't have
to know it for now.
So I just put
it down here
on the bottom in gray.
Dapnomycin profile,
G absorption, poor,
so it's only IV.
Distribution,
body fluids,
high protein binding,
low ***********
of unenflamed
meninges, all
the same thing
we've been seeing
all this time.
So it's easy to
remember the differences
because you've already
learned class effects.
An OK half
-life, of course,
renal, renal impairment,
adjust the dosage.
PKPD profile, this
is concentration
dependent and
it does have
prolonged
persistent effects.
And clinical
effect, as with the
rest, is associated
with the AUC-MIC
ratio and it is
bactericidal. Okay,
so what's different
about this one?
Well, the mechanism
for one thing.
And this is a
proposed mechanism of
action based on
experimental observations.
It appears that this
tail, this lipid
tail, goes into
the membrane, and
along with calcium,
it will form this
complex, and it
will form a hole,
and from this hole,
ions will escape.
and as that happens
there is a rest of DNA
RNA and protein
synthesis and when that
happens rapid cell
death notice that cell
lysis does not occur
we're not talking
about osmotic lysis
because of a cell wall
action or lysis because
of any other reason.
It's just the leakage
of ions and the
arrest of DNA, RNA,
and protein synthesis.
Taptomycin is
active against, oh,
here we go again,
gram positive only.
Aerobic, facultative
anaerobic, obligate
anaerobic, so anything
gram positive,
basically. Oh, here
we go again, MRSA,
VESA, VERSA, V
-R-E. Okay, what
do all those
letters mean?
All right, MRSA,
you know that.
Methicillin
-resistant staph
aureus, staph
epidermidis.
Vancomycin-intermediate
sensitivity.
Sorry, vancomycin
-intermediate
staph aureus.
Vancomycin
-resistant staph
aureus. So, VERSA, MRSA.
Vancomycin-resistant
enterococci sounds
pretty bad we want
vancomycin to be useful
well when these resistances
occur we do have
the alternative of
daptomycin complicated
skin and soft tissue
infections endocarditis
bloodstream infections
osteomyelitis
septic arthritis
meningitis on and on for
all of these various
infections caused by
these resistant gram
-positive organisms.
So you can see
a blank square
here. What's
special about it?
There is an interesting
characteristic
with daptomycin that
you really must know.
Daptomycin is inactivated
by pulmonary surfactants.
So, of course,
it's not going
to be useful
for pneumonia
as it concentrates
in the lungs and is
inactivated by the
pulmonary surfactants.
And because it's
useful only against
gram-positive,
anything gram
-negative is
inherently resistant.
Simple to remember.
Very simple drug.
Simple like vancomycin.
You can think
of them together
because they're so
similar in their
spectrum of activity, but
totally different
in their mechanism.
Daptomycin can
cause myopathy.
So breakage of
skeletal muscle,
weakness in
pain in skeletal
muscle, And in the worst
case scenario,
breakage of those lysis
of the skeletal
muscle cells that can
lead to rhabdomyolysis
or rhabdomyolysis.
So what do we do?
Do we withdraw the
drug? Well, we might
have to, but we
want to prevent it.
So how do we prevent
it? By monitoring
the creatine fossil
kinase levels.
As these levels,
the creatine
kinase levels increase,
it is the result
of lysis of
the skeletal
muscle cells.
Also, if the patient
has new onset or
worsening muscle pain
or weakness, that's
another indication
of the myopathy.
Now, in addition,
we could look for
peripheral neuropathy,
fever infiltrates,
hypersensitivity
reactions, of course,
always, and daptomycin
hypersensitivity
reactions can
cause some serious
adverse effects,
both immediate and
delayed, skin and
systemic symptoms.
Can we use it in
pregnancy? Well, there
isn't a whole lot
of information on
that. If we're going
to be saving the
life of the mother
and daptomycin is
the only effective
drug, that's going
to have to be a risk
-benefit decision.
The drug is
excreted in breast
milk and there is dosing
guidance for
pediatric patients.
all right think
myopathy think
about what other
drugs can cause
myopathy and
that's statins
statins i'm sure you've
heard of along the
way in your lifetime
are these drugs for
the treatment of high
blood cholesterol
hypercholesterolemia
millions and millions of
patients are on statins
So we need to be
thinking about this
drug-drug interaction
monitor.
So in summary,
I'm not going
to read this all to you.
There's quite a bit. It's
everything that
we talked about.
I put a summary of
some adverse effects
here of the different
drugs and vancomycin.
and daptomycin and
please remember
unnecessary outpatient
antibiotic use
endangers kids one
because of increasing
the risk of resistant
organisms and putting
them in harm's
way for adverse
effects of the drugs we
don't use antibiotics
unless the patient
has a bacterial
infection. That's it.
So that concludes
the two lectures
on this very, very,
very important
category of
antibiotics, the beta
-lactams, vancomycin,
so the glycopeptide,
and daptomycin,
the lipopeptide.